[Music]
so andrew schultz
was on
adam was on no jumper basically right
um
and of course
brendan schaub came up
do you want to hear what they had to say
i need to hear it yeah
so okay we've so far we've talked about
gang shootings we've talked about
abortion
let's talk about something that is
perhaps even more disturbing okay gringo
poppy
oh boy
you and i you want some clips you and i
are both yes so do i thought friends
youtube he and i are both friends of
brendan's shop yeah shout out to
brentwood former ufc fighter current
comedian and podcaster
i know you see it people for some reason
they want anyone associated with
brenda's shop to speak out against him
because no no see this is
they're doing this again and no that's
not what it is i don't give a [ __ ]
if you guys no one needs to publicly
come out and say they hate brendan i
don't give a [ __ ] if the people do that
don't what i hate is the phoniness
that you're pretending he's good that's
what bothers me there's a difference
right i don't give a [ __ ] there's a
bunch of people don't talk about him who
gives a [ __ ]
because they don't like his comedy
special
he has a he has a reddit page that is
like is is massive it will make you
scared to have a reddit yeah and it's
like dedicated to
yeah just [ __ ] on him and it's it's
really unfortunate because like we got
one two now um do you guys have the yeah
it's pretty malicious
yeah it's uh it's an interesting thing
because reddit is
fascinating and [ __ ] hilarious and so
what you're saying is
it's not because gringo poppy is
objectively bad
it's because the redditors are mean
i'm trying to understand is that what
they're saying i suppose it's an
organized
campaign of harassment
like there are apps like creative people
on there and basically what it is is
it's like your reddit page is giving
thousands of people that might not have
their own instagram or twitter that's
popping no access to
that's popping
yeah bro popping okay no cap
wait group instagram that's popping
that's what a reddit page is right so
now they have access to 50 000 people or
whatever it is and if they put something
out that slaps it gets
it slaps
why is he talking like this
because he's andrew schultz oh it's
views and it gets reactions and all of a
sudden you get to almost feel
like you're popping because you're
popping the content is crushing so
you're gonna question keep on leaning
into that so it incentivizes them to be
as mean as possible because that's the
stuff that rises to the top it's the
[ __ ] that's the
andrew schultz talks the way adam looks
exactly and then you guys you got to be
good at like making sure like we're like
the mods i guess have to be good at
making sure the whole page is healthy
because like a jewish
hip-hop mogul
yeah like like like he would be on vlad
tv he sounds like like a like a jewish a
r guy for a hip-hop label
yep
at the end of the day like you don't
want that page to take away from the
content i think that's unfortunately
what's happening with the fight on the
kid like they have a [ __ ] great
podcast like
is it do they though great podcast it's
so awesome
they're hilarious together
are they
really
really
really papa
huh dicey dicey anybody really papa yeah
papa
like brian and brendan are [ __ ]
hilarious
stop saying it no
you look you can repeat it as many times
as you want andrew you keep saying it
andrew i guess the more you say it the
more it's like i feel like you're trying
to convince yourself all right yeah it's
so great yeah
do you think a bunch of people have to
go look
richard pryor was funny okay
he was funny
if you search brennan's job right now
the thing that's going around the most
was that theo van stuff though oh i know
i saw the views i saw the views of the
clip we had it blew up
together and uh and brennan's like a
really great dude he's a he's a
genuinely sweet dude unless you're bobby
lee then he'll try to ruin your entire
[ __ ] life yeah
really great guy unless you're crystalia
and you just stop talking to him
publicly or brian gallon or anybody on
youtube that's criticizing him
but unless you're those people
who helps people he's the reason i got
on rogan like he was like yo you've got
to get this guy on this is before
anybody was [ __ ] and again
they exposed they're exposing a goddamn
business
they're saying the reason why they
defend him not they're not saying things
like that special was great he kills
they're saying things like he helped me
get on rogan
yeah and that's the thing that we've
been pointing out since day one but by
the way this is not everyone's making
fun of brendan but you know we were
pointing this stuff out for a while like
it it's it's the same it's the same
thing it's it's because of his
connections and because of who he's
friends with not because he's good ask
yourself this question if brandon chop
was the same thing but he wasn't on
rogan or wasn't rogan's friend do you
really think that people would be
sucking his dick this much
i'm looking at my [ __ ] like
and that really changed my life so he's
actually a great by the way if all you
guys want to keep sucking his dick
just get into his f-150 raptor
dude and um
he's just getting destroyed i just don't
understand this like
he sucks you know
by that thing i told him to lean into it
i was like bro you got to sell merch
like anything that they do about you you
got to lean in and then i thought that
they i will agree with that can i agree
with andrew there on that if he were to
lean in on it
his life would be easier you know yeah
instead of defending it they would
appreciate that in one way they're like
oh okay he's not ignoring and acting
like this thing isn't happening this is
he's like taking part of this thing his
reddit is so [ __ ] up that like they've
made it their mission to expose him
cheating that
that's where it's like yo you going into
the personal life that's that's that's
wild man why are they no no no no no no
no no no no no look the writer might
have done that but
the person who did that
is on trash tuesday
don't
excuse me the reason that that went out
of the reddit and into the universe
wasn't because of any drama channels
talking about that no it was because
original parties because the the the the
three boars went on [ __ ] trash
tuesday and started talking about it
saying oh his name is bs and he's not
funny and you that's why this happened
come on be honest at least who put the
dirty laundry out there
hey
so they're like that deep into his life
where there's people probably following
him around like security cam footage and
[ __ ] it's different it's different when
you have a group of people who are
basically commenting on the stuff that
you're putting out into the world and
it's different when they become
basically like a large league of private
investigators who are gonna like
overturn every rock throughout your life
and find everything that they could
possibly do because that's kind of where
his [ __ ] is at yeah yeah yeah it's
honestly i don't really care about his
personal life that much the only reason
we even talked about the personal
lifestyle was because they talked about
it on jurassic tuesday
if you look back to all at least us the
what we've made fun of him it's not
really because of his personal life ever
don't really
we're making fun of how bit he's a
mushmouth and not funny yeah that's the
main that to us is that's the brit
that's that's what we like making fun of
with him
yeah i mean you you know brandon like
you guys are close or what well we did
the interview but that's all that's
no
totally honest
i saw the first
six or seven minutes of the special so
these
[ __ ]
haven't even
watched the special this is what they
hear you're defending something you
haven't even seen
because they don't want to see it we saw
clips of it on our show i've watched the
whole thing on my own
all of it
it's bad
it's very bad
too much more of it uh i think he's a
good guy i'm not like a big fan of his
comedy but i mean i [ __ ] with a lot of
people where i don't really like that
rapping yeah and we're still cool right
like that's not the entirety of who you
are as a person
agreed
i know that's not the entirety of who he
is as a person
the problem is
is that
you guys
are
every when joe rogan was going against
mencia all
of these people started getting on joe
rogan's side right like yeah you know
[ __ ] this med see a guy he's stealing oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] him
but
when brendan by the way he was also
stolen jokes we've shown that as well
is doing it it's like look i don't [ __ ]
with you all
okay fine you might like brendan as a
person that's fine but that doesn't mean
that we can't make fun of gringo poppy
right
yeah no that should be allowed yeah
based on your own standards exactly
he is a just fine rapper dude
[ __ ] looked at me i'm like
i don't like josh's raps i still [ __ ]
with him he
advised him not to i advised him not to
drop the hashbrown town k mixtape i
think that they're a good dude right
yeah and yeah i mean like comedies like
anything else you like get better at it
if you put the time in
agreed listen it's not even that we're
mad that he's a new comic starting up
and he's bad it's that
he was put on show time because of rogan
like
that's the thing that bothers me
you know
at the same time shane gillis wasn't
[ __ ] allowed to be on snl this guy's
getting a showtime special you know
yeah yeah
a lot of justice in the world yeah
that's the point
so like i think a lot of people don't
realize that like brendan's like very
early into his comedy career like i told
him i was like i think you put the like
even when he did that first special i
think it was just too early this [ __ ]
takes a while bro like you need
i mean most people say like a decade
before you're like starting to get nice
[ __ ]
yeah bro i wonder
i've done i've done like five shows
yeah
then you're not
doing
you're not really a comedian yet if
you've done five shows right here
but within the last one is that's fat
joe right
is it i don't know i mean i'm probably
it looks like him
see that's not even enough
like he's like
back in new york when i was coming up i
was doing like 12 a week yeah i've
kicked it i have the skill set and then
eventually
develop the skill exactly and that's
where it's very difficult yeah i don't
want to hear listen guys i don't want to
hear about the craft craft to be honest
with you i don't force to go get up on
stage and tell jokes i would be you know
nervous as [ __ ] i know all these things
are true but that doesn't stop him from
sucking
i i think that's more the point of this
i love when they give him credit for
going up there and doing it so somebody
said
somebody sent me this clip marsh and and
and i and i timestamped it and they sent
it with a timestamp so thank you so much
and it's you could already tell that
it's the most replayed part this is from
a few months ago
um
there's some january on on fighter and
the kid
you want to see what a sore loser
brendan is so apparently he lost the
race to the guy on the right okay like a
foot race
but instead of just losing like a man
watch this explosion yeah
but my ankles and my calves they've
never been the same actually they've
actually never been the same they've
never didn't ever cover their problems
yeah
it wasn't i've always had any issues
though i stopped for this one time they
could get their [ __ ] together i mean
even he's always had hammy issues watch
with the hemis you were still running
so we're not so we're not running it
back yeah you want to watch the actual
produced one or the the christian's
version
he lost the race that's why you see look
i want you look at brennan he lost his
foot race he's acting like a child when
a child loses watch
chris is just christians just straight
away
do you have a side by side so i can see
where chappelle is yeah no one got the
let's see we'll watch this all together
chabelle's going to get into his his
fifth gear here and at this point he was
in his fourth gear
so
pull it up let's watch this one pull it
up frozen i'm sorry he looks like you're
frozen i'm sorry
no
okay watch this
yeah see this is right there's right
right there you can see he's
right there he's look at the way you're
walking there he goes right there you
can see
nice
now you guys were pretty neck and neck
everybody neck
he hurt his hammy look he stopped now
he's faking the injury you know when a
kid loses that's what i said it's a fair
matchup yeah it'd be fun to [ __ ] find
out
he's so mad look at how mad he is that
he lost look at him
he's a child
no i don't think i care
enough first of all you were pushing us
you woke up this
morning yeah dude
you woke up this my hammies oh my
hammies my hams oh god my injury
it's like a kid right my hammy hands
yeah if i weren't hurt i would have
totally yeah i would have beat him up
yeah
look at that good that's all you can say
sometimes i think my sponsor
uh team bieber
you know uh he's been sponsoring me
through this whole
he's race mad
he can't he can't lose
he can't
what but but he does lose all the time i
know right you think you'd think he
would get used to it by now yeah